l'équilibre qui est proposé dans le
texte que le gouvernement a mis sur la
table nous paraît le bon puisqu'il
permet à la fois de rétablir l'équilibre
à moyen terme de du régime du système de
retraite pour être plus large du système
de retraite et dans le même temps
d'embarquer un certain nombre de mesures
de solidarité qui nous paraissent
absolument essentiel je citerai 4 qui
nous nous
interpelle ou du moins nous que nous
accompagnons très clairement à la CPME
alors il y a évidemment le dispositif
d'usure professionnelle j'y reviendrai
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment la
création d'un droit nouveau un droit à
la prévention de l'usure professionnelle
qui n'existe pas actuellement dans le
code du travail et qui est une novation
qu'apporterait le texte qui est qui est
aujourd'hui qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui j'y reviendrai parce que
c'est un sujet pour la CME très
important et qui est très lié
le dispositif de carrière longue auquel
nous sommes aussi très attachés le
deuxième point effectivement c'est la
question des minimas de pension avec la
possibilité pour toutes les carrières
complètes
passer et à venir de bénéficier d'une
pension qui soit au moins égale à 85 %
d'un SMIC pour une carrière complète
[Musique]